harris defends jackson protect the wall
reggie
[Applause]
five to go reggie from the lead hot damn
what a shot
reggie jackson are you ready for your
close-up
when you see this team unity of the
clippers they are pulling for each other
who is one of the first guys over there
luke bernard
congratulating reggie who's
now three of eight from the three-point
line luke 7 of 11 off two screens
is there a switch yes there is a little
fake left when he steps back right
knocks down that shot wide open look
it's only a two-pointer i thought
initially it was a three but it's only a
two
orlando still has a chance to pull this
one out with 2.2 to play that said
as we pointed out earlier reggie is
giving you everything he has every
single night
and today in the fourth quarter a wizard
he has nine of his 25 in the final frame
and the potential game winner
now the clippers need to defend without
fouling
remember he shot that over wendell
carter jr who's 6-10
but he created that space with a little
move to his left and step back to his
right
plenty of time
well cole anthony can get the job done
and the clippers cannot lose sight of
him 2.2 to play watch the man taking the
ball out of bounds oftentimes he's the
most dangerous after he passes if he
cuts and moves without it flippers
looking for a stop it goes to ross the
three for the win
106 to 104 the clippers hold on reggie
jackson puts the clippers out in front
for good
[Applause]
just a great effort
you told that team coaching staff
players involved to win this game when
orlando played really well make big shot
after big shot and hang on it